I AM JONATHAN HUNT.
NOW BACK TO "HANNITY."
♪ ♪
>> Sean: OUR OPENING MONOLOGUE
MONOLOGUE, CORRUPT DEEP STATE
ACTORS MAY HAVE TROUBLE SLEEPING
TONIGHT AFTER THE REPORTS THAT
AUNTIE TRUMP DOSSIER
AUTHOR CHRISTOPHER STEELE SAT
DOWN FOR 15 HOURS OF INTERVIEWS.
HERE TO REACT, PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
ATTORNEY, RUDY GIULIANI IS HERE.
MR. MAYOR, ALL THIS NEWS, HE
GAVE 15 HOURS OF TESTIMONY, AND
ARE FINALLY OTHERS DECIDED LAST
MINUTE THAT THEY WANT TO TALK TO
HOROWITZ.
THEN WE LEARN ABOUT
GENERAL FLYNN.
YOU ARE A PROSECUTOR.
I DON'T LIKE HIS PRACTICE.
YOU GOT TO GET -- YOU GET     GT
YOU GOT TO GET -- YOU GET     GA
YOU GOT TO GET -- YOU GET     GG
YOU GOT TO GET -- YOU GET     GT
YOU GOT TO GET -- YOU GET     GE
OUT OF JAIL FREE CARD IF YOU
JUST SAY WHAT YOU WE WANT YOU TO
SAY.
>> THAT'S IN ANDREW WEISSMANN
SPECIAL THAT MUELLER TOLERATED.
MUELLER SHOULD NEVER HAVE BEEN
TOLERATED, INDEPENDENT COUNSEL,
SERIOUS COUNSEL, SLEEP COUNSEL.
HE DID THE SAME THING IN THE
"WHITEY" BULGER CASE.
A FEDERAL JUDGE NAMED NANCY
BURTON, A CLASSMATE OF THE
CLINTONS, SAID THAT HIS HANDLING
OF THAT WHOLE THING WAS A
SERIOUS PROBLEM FOR THE FBI.
IT WAS CHILLING IN THE WAY THAT
HE COVERED UP FOR A COUPLE OF
FBI RATS WHO ACTUALLY DID THE
MURDERS, AND PEOPLE SPENT 40
YEARS IN PRISON FOR MURDER AS
THEY DID NOT COMMIT.
OTHER PEOPLE COMMITTED THEM AND
THE FBI KNEW ALL ALONG.
I'M KIND OF NOT MAKING THIS UP.
THE U.S. ATTORNEY OF CONNECTICUT
KNOWS THIS CASE BETTER THAN ME.
HE UNCOVERED AT.
MUELLER IS THE GUY WHO HAS
TOLERATED THIS KIND OF
INCOMPETENT, UNETHICAL,
OVER-THE-TOP BEHAVIOR IN DEFENSE
OF THE INSTITUTION.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HIS MAKEUP IS
BUT I DID NOT REALLY FOCUS ON
ALL THIS UNTIL I GOT INVOLVED IN
THE CASE.
I WAS SHOCKED.
I WAS SHOCKED AT THE WAY THEY
HANDLE THIS CASE.
TOTALLY OUT OF CONTROL.
>> Sean: MR. MAYOR, YOU CAN'T
OFFER A GET OUT OF JAIL FREE
CARD AND FEED PEOPLE WANT YOU
WANT THEM TO SAY.
SPEAKER YOU CAN'T PUT A MAN LIKE
PAUL MANAFORT IN SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT AND BRING HIM IN 13
TIMES LIKE ANDREW WEISSMANN DID,
TELL THEM WHAT TO SAY, WHEN HE
TELLS YOU IT'S NOT TRUE, I SENT
HIM BACK TO SOLITARY CONFINEMENT
AND BRING HIM OUT OF WORK OR
MORE DAYS UNLESS THEY ARE TRYING
TO SUBORNED PERJURY OR YOU DON'T
CARE IF THEY ARE SUBORNING
PERJURY.
YOU CAN'T DO WHAT HE DID TO
JEROME CORSI.
I HAVE THE DOCUMENTS ON THAT.
THEY GOT HIM RED-HANDED AND OUT.
THAT WHEN WE HAD TO GO TO THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND GET THEM
SLAPPED ACROSS THE FACE FOR
BEING UNETHICAL, DISGRACEFUL
PROSECUTORS, WHICH IS WHAT THEY
ARE.
ALL THIS WHILE IONIZING MUELLER
IS DISGRACEFUL AND THAT IS WHAT
YOU WILL FIND OUT.
THESE GUYS ARE THE GUYS I NEED
TO BE INVESTIGATED.
>> Sean: WE'VE BEEN
INVESTIGATING THE INVESTIGATORS.
WE ARE LEARNING AN AWFUL LOT
THAT I DON'T LIKE.
I WANT TRUTH AND JUSTICE BUT YOU
I WANT TRUTH AND JUSTICE BUT YOY
CAN SAY, SING OR COMPOSE OR WE
WILL PUT YOU IN JAIL.
SAY WHAT YOU WANT --
>> ONLY IF YOU ARE THE LIBERAL
MEDIA, WHICH MAKES YOU INTO SOME
KIND OF A KING FOR DOING THAT,
AND A PRINCE.
WHEN IN FACT, THIS IS LIKE --
THIS IS THE SCOURGE OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE CIVIL LIBERTARIANS,
PROSECUTORS LIKE THIS.
THAT IS WHY YOU HAVE A GUY LIKE
ALAN DERSHOWITZ IN SHOCK THAT
THESE PEOPLE ARE BEING LIONIZED
LIKE THIS.
>> Sean: HOW DOES MUELLER
JUSTIFY FARA INVESTIGATIONS --
YOU AND I BOTH KNOW THAT IS
USUALLY FELL OUT THE FORM, SEE
YOU LATER, OR LONE APPLICATIONS,
OR TAXI MEDALLIONS, AND TAXES
FROM A DECADE GONE BY.
IGNORE STEELE'S DIRTY DOSSIER,
THAT THE OTHER CANDIDATE -- THAT
WAS USED TO SPY ON A CAMPAIGN.
>> HE WAS A HIT MAN.
HE WASN'T -- HE WOULD NOT OF
HIRED ANDREW WEISSMANN IF HE
DIDN'T CARE ABOUT THE TRUTH,
WHAT HE?
HE WOULD NOT FIRE JEANNIE RHEE,
THE COUNSEL TO THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION.
>> Sean: PUT YOU IN JAIL AND I
WILL BE RIGHT NEXT TO YOU.
>> I WOULD NOT HIRE PEOPLE LIKE
THAT.
I WOULD HAVE KICKED THEM OUT.
WHEN HE DID THAT, I SAID TO
MYSELF, WHAT THE HECK IS WRONG
WITH HIM?
I FIGURED OUT WHAT IS WRONG WITH
HIM.
HE'S BASICALLY ASLEEP.
THE REALITY IS THAT THIS WAS A
PLOT FROM THE VERY BEGINNING TO
FRAME TRUMP.
THAT IS WHAT YOU WILL FIND OUT.
IT'S RATHER COMPLEX.
IT HAS A WHOLE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE SPIN TO IT.
IT'S GOING TO GET WORSE AND
WORSE AND WORSE.
WHY IS THIS THE FIRST TIME
SOMEBODY SAT DOWN WITH STEELE
FOR 16 HOURS?
COMEY NEVER DID IT?
IT WAS UNVERIFIED?
YOU ARE THE DIRECTOR OF THE FBI.
YOU ARE SUPPOSED TO VERIFY,
JERK.
YOU ARE SUPPOSED TO VERIFY.
DON'T TELL ME YOU CAN'T VERIFY.
MAN, I WOULD HAVE THROWN HIM OUT
OF THE OFFICE OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
YOU COME TO ME AND YOU TELL ME
THE THING IS UNVERIFIED AND YOU
HAVE HAD IT FOR FOUR MONTHS?
YOU HAVEN'T BOTHERED TO VERIFY
IT?
FIND OUT AS A BUNCH OF CRAP?
>> Sean: HE SIGHED OFTEN
OCTOBER 16 --
>> FOUR MONTHS TO VERIFY IT.
HE SHOULD HAVE AN EMBARRASSED
WALKING TO THE PRESIDENT-ELECT
OF THE UNITED STATES AND SAYINGI
OF THE UNITED STATES AND SAYING'
OF THE UNITED STATES AND SAYINGS
OF THE UNITED STATES AND SAYINGU
OF THE UNITED STATES AND SAYINGV
OF THE UNITED STATES AND SAYINGR
OF THE UNITED STATES AND SAYINGF
OF THE UNITED STATES AND SAYINGE
OF THE UNITED STATES AND SAYING.
UNVERIFIED!
YOU HAD FOUR MONTHS TO VERIFY IT
AND YOU RUN THE MOST CONFIDENT,
EFFECTIVE LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY
IN THE WORLD, OR AT LEAST WEEKLY
MEDIA, AND YOU RUINED IT, PAL,
BECAUSE THEY ARE ALL ASHAMED OF
YOU.
THEY SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF
MUELLER.
YOU LOOK BACK ON MUELLER'S
RECORD NOW WITH AN EYE AT WHAT
HE WAS DOING AND YOU LOOK AT THE
WHOLE "WHITEY" BULGER THING AND
YOU SAY, WOW, THIS WAS
PROTECTABLE.
>> Sean: WHAT DO YOU PREDICT
ON WEDNESDAY?
BECAUSE I THINK WHEN JIM JORDAN
AND DOUG COLLINS AND MATT GAETZ
AND A FEW OTHERS ASK THESE
QUESTIONS, HOW DID YOU
INVESTIGATE THESE THINGS BUT NOT
THE DIRTY DOSSIER FOR MUCH OF
THAT WAS USED TO REALLY
INFLUENCE THE ELECTION, AND USED
TO SPY ON THE OPPOSITION
PARTY?
>> HOW DID YOU DO THE
INVESTIGATION IN THE FIRST PLACE
WHEN YOUR LEAD AGENT,
PETER STRZOK, DID THE ORIGINAL
INVESTIGATION AND CONCLUDED
THERE WAS NO EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION?
HE TEXTED TO HIS GIRLFRIEND,
THERE'S NO THERE THERE.
HE DID NOT TELL YOU THERE IS NO
THERE THERE?
HE TOLD HIS GIRLFRIEND BUT NOT
YOU?
WHY, BECAUSE YOU DON'T SHOW UP
AT THE OFFICE BECAUSE YOU ARE
BEHIND AN IRON CURTAIN?
I SAW THE GUY ONE TIME.
IN A YEAR AND A HALF.
I HEARD HIM SPEAK FOR AN HOUR
AND A HALF ONE TIME.
I CALLED HIM "THE WIZARD OF OZ"
BECAUSE HE WAS BEHIND THE
CURTAIN.
"WE ARE GOING TO TAKE IT TO
BOB."
BOB IS IN CHARGE, PAL.
WHEN I WAS THE U.S. ATTORNEY, I
WAS IN CHARGE, I WAS IN CHARGE
OF THE COMMISSION CASE, I WAS IN
CHARGE OF THE CASE -- I WAS IN
CHARGE, NOT A BUNCH OF
ASSISTANCE.
SURE, THEY HELPED A LOT.
BUT I WAS NOT BEHIND SOME IRON
CURTAIN OR SOME CURTAIN.
HE WILL BE OUT OF THE CURTAIN
AND WE WILL FIND OUT ANSWERS AND
LET'S SEE IF BOB CAN ANSWER THE
THEM.
>> Sean: I THINK HE IS GOING
TO HAVE A TOUGH TIME WEDNESDAY.
IT'S NOT GOING TO GO THE WAY THE
MEDIA THINKS.
MR. MAYOR, GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> I DOUBT IT.
IT WILL BE VERY INTERESTING TO
SEE IF HE DOES ANOTHER STUMBLING
AND BUMBLING LOCATED FOR HIS
9 MINUTES.
>> Sean: ATTORNEY GENERAL
BARR, MY THEORY, THEY ALSO MET
WITH A JOINT STATEMENT.
>> BILL IS A GOOD GUY AND A
GREAT ATTORNEY GENERAL.
NOT GOING TO CRITICIZE BILL.
>> Sean: ABOUT CRITICIZING
HIM.
I SAID HE TRIED TO --
>> MAYBE HE GAVE HIM A LIFELINE,
HE DID NOT TAKE IT.
[LAUGHS]